are you ready to hit the headlines with
sj let's do it
um because our first story actually is
about two people that you know so would
you take this story please okay
uh a big congratulations to priyanka
chopra and nick jonas they just welcomed
their first baby into the world with the
help of a surrogate
they announced on instagram and asked
for privacy as they celebrate this
special time i'm so
excited for them they are such special
human beings they made us feel family
this year when we celebrated diwali with
them yeah and i could not be happier for
them i'm i'm so excited for them it's
beautiful that's so great
wonderful if you went from a jonas
brother now he's a jonas daddy how cute
is that and they have one baby now all
they need is two more to make a little
jonas baby band i can't wait no now
they're all dad i know
it's so exciting i feel like everybody
roots for them and this is just no
exception congratulations
congrats great story well next we're
looking at an age-old question posed by
women's day magazine we want your take
on this everyone's heard of that term
soul mates i want to find my soul mate
well they're asking is that real
everyone's got their own answer but some
relationship experts caution the concept
of soul mates could be dangerous it
could lead to some people focusing too
much on finding the one instead of
building that soulmate connection with
somebody special think about that so
they say basically soul mates takes work
what do you think
well drew and ross do you want the truth
or do you want i want the truth
or do you want to feel good oh i want to
she wants the truth i want to feel good
go i was going to say the first thing
that came to my mind was the lizzo song
soulmate i think it's a great song and
she says i'm my own soul mate yeah
really really nice message uh but you
know the thing is that i think a
soulmate is someone or a mate that helps
you find your soul and my mates can't
even help me find my keys so i'm like
i'm like not so sure i think my take on
this is
i believe that there are people out
there but there are multiple soul mates
and we're going to meet them at
different times in our life and they
help us find a different part of
ourselves and what you just said though
a mate who helps you find your soul is
like
right that's humungo because i do think
the idea that there's one person and you
either find them or you live miserably
your whole life is ridiculous because it
infers that relationships aren't any
work yeah and i i think it's because
there's so many movies where the
princess finds the prince and then they
live happily ever after they say and it
ends but what they don't show is that
the prince has sleep apnea and the
princess has bad credit they don't show
you that
and so we have these expectations
that are impossible oh my god ross we
need to produce a rom-com together
please happily ever after after yeah
yeah i couldn't agree more i was so
excited to hear your take on this
because you
did find someone extraordinary
um who you met when you were a monk
and weren't available and then when it
was the right time you were open to
receiving each other yeah and it's taken
a lot of work and it's still work every
single day but i think the point of a
soulmate is who are you willing to put
that work in for yeah you're always
trying to change the other person and
usually you're trying to change them to
be a bit more like you like why are you
not organized like me or why are you not
this like me and then you realize i
don't want to be married to me i don't
want to date myself no i want to be with
someone else who gives me a unique
perspective and brings something fresh
and i think letting go of that
has been the best decision can you
imagine dating yourself i know can you
oh my god would i if i dated myself i
would break up with myself so fast i'd
be like get out of here i i i don't know
what it would be like to date myself i
have no perspective it would be funny
though yeah
we've seen all those decorative wooden
plaques with the words live laugh love
on them well this one is so awesome this
story because apparently the phrase has
become a huge
joke for gen c okay yahoo life reports
that live laugh love is being now mocked
by millions of people especially the
younger ones on tick tock every day some
in sort of this tone like this video do
you see this kelly look it says
live
laugh
love
isn't that precious you know we don't
have anything over the couch in the den
i guess i'm gonna have to get it it's
just too
it's just too perfect for a family live
love love so simple
okay so that's one approach but they're
also using it like i just got ghosted
again live laugh love
i just filed for bankruptcy live laugh
love jay what's your take on live laugh
love well you know i'm gonna play a bit
of devil's advocate here right i think
we need a little more live laugh love in
our life but not not on a plaque not not
in your home you know i think it's
interesting i like like you say i like
the sentiment to put that out there live
laugh love good right it's just signs of
words on walls like when you walk into
someone's kitchen and they have a big
sign that says eat i'm like i know
or whether you go in the bedroom it says
sleep or dreams yeah i get it
what what does it say in your bathroom
because i know what to do there too
that's brilliant but the sentiment is
true
in fact we just wrote for the magazine
the new issue we're making like for the
heart issue i wrote if there are cracks
in your heart let that be space for
light to shine through
um
[Applause]
[Music]
you